we've spent an entire week with apple's
brand new ipad air 4.
so instead of focusing on the specs like
everybody else does
i'm going to explain why apple gave the
air the features
that it has including things like the
modern design
and the all-new touch id power button
because if the new ipad air 4 does
one thing and one thing only it gives us
a glimpse into the future of apple's
ipad lineup
but before we get into all of that let's
talk about what makes the ipad air seem
like
such a great deal
[Music]
as you already know the biggest standout
feature of the new ipad
air is the modern design that came from
the pro
with rounded corners on the display and
flat edges
just like the iphone 12 and because of
that design
we of course get support for the second
generation apple pencil
which is an absolute game changer
compared to the first one
thanks to wireless charging and pairing
we also finally get a usbc
port just like the pro has and this is
honestly a very big deal
because lightning was so limiting in
terms of connecting accessories like
storage and
displays now if you're wondering why
apple gave
the air the same design as the ipad pro
there are two
main reasons the first one is so that
the new air supports the same
magic keyboard case as the pro and this
is huge for apple
because if you're not willing to spend
between 800
and a thousand dollars on an ipad pro
apple can
instead sell you on the new ipad air for
six hundred dollars
and then upsell the magic keyboard and
for reason number two
as soon as the 2018 ipad pro came out
with the new redesign
the ipad air 3 took on the previous
generation ipad pro's
10.5 inch chassis so it seems like the
air is the little sibling that gets all
the hand-me-downs
now apart from the new design the ipad
air just works
great the display is excellent for an
lcd panel
everything feels very snappy performance
is incredible with the new a14 bionic
chip
which by the way is much more powerful
than the a14 and the iphone 12
but i'll get into that in just a moment
a really weird choice was to give the
ipad
air 4 a brand new touch id power button
instead of just giving it face id like i
personally was expecting
but what makes it even more weird is
just how far
apple went out of their way to not put
face id
on the new air two vice presidents from
apple called the touch id power button
in incredible feat of engineering saying
that there was a ton of work
trying to figure out how to make the
cellular model antennas
work with the new touch id location
along with a bunch of algorithm work
as well and i'm willing to bet that it
actually cost
apple more money to create this new
touch id power button
than to simply just put face id on the
ipad air
and this shows just how hard apple was
willing to work
to keep face id and ipad pro exclusive
feature
now you might be asking why well apple
had to be very careful
to make sure that the ipad air is a nice
upgrade
but not nice enough to make the ipad pro
look like a bad value
compared to the air that's why the air
doesn't get the larger camera bump
with the ultra wide camera and the lidar
scanner that's why the air's usb-c
port isn't as fast as the one on the pro
they even went as far as to put
basically the same
exact display panel into the air but
they gave it thicker bezels
so that it would only be 10.9 inches
instead of 11 inches on the pro and even
though
it's the same exact panel the ipad air
doesn't get 120 hertz promotion
technology because
that's an ipad pro feature getting even
deeper
that same exact panel on the air is
limited to 500 nits of brightness
compared to 600 nits
on the pro this is exactly the same
thing they did
on the iphone 12 lineup the regular 6.1
inch iphone 12
can only get up to 625 nits of typical
brightness
compared to 800 on the 6.1 inch iphone
12
pro even though they have identical
display panels
and identical battery sizes apple even
gave the ipad air 4 speaker grilles
but it only gets dual stereo speakers
compared to
quad speakers on the pro because once
again
apple needs the pro to stand out and to
make it even more
interesting the speaker grills on the
new air
are quite a bit larger which makes you
think that the quality is better
but it's not just listen to this sound
[Music]
comparison
[Music]
so in that case why the new speaker
grills on the air
well i personally believe that these new
larger grills
are going into the 2021 ipad pro
next year and that ipad pro is also
getting
the new mini led display which this air
obviously doesn't have and it might not
have for a while
since that feature alone will cause
people
to pay more for the pro which is apple's
end goal
now since apple tried so hard to avoid
giving face id to the ipad air
you can bet that this exact touch id
power button sensor
is gonna go into the rest of apple's
lower end
ipads like next year's redesigned ipad
mini
and that new mini will also get the
redesign with the flat sides
which means it's getting the second
generation apple pencil
the new modern display with rounded
corners probably speaker grilles on both
sides
and it's almost certainly getting a
price bump
from the current 399 dollars to 499
dollars
however the budget 329 ipad
is probably gonna stick with the older
design for at least
one more year and i'm willing to bet
that the 2021 budget ipad
will quite literally have the same frame
as the 10.5 inch ipad air 3. and i'm
willing to bet
that the new one is going to come with
the 813 bionic chip
and it's going to start at a higher 399
all of this wild speculation can be made
just by
analyzing the features that apple put
into the ipad air 4
as well as looking into apple's trends
from the past
like them recycling older ipad frames
into
lower end ipads but getting back into
the new ipad air
let's talk about the performance of the
a14 bionic chip
while the cpu performance is still
behind the pros a12 z
chip the graphics performance is what
really matters
because that's the main limitation and
with the e14
it's absolutely insane being better than
the ipad pro
which we didn't expect from apple's own
performance gain numbers that they gave
us during the september event
the a14 chip basically means that games
and apps are going to run as smooth as
butter on the new ipad air 4. and apple
might seem a bit crazy
for making the air so close to the ipad
pro
especially in terms of graphics
performance but keep in mind
that the pro hasn't really been upgraded
since 2008
yes i know there's the new 2020 ipad pro
but that was barely improved at all the
a12z
chip is quite literally the same exact
chip as the a12x
except that they enabled the 8th
graphics core
that's it in my personal opinion i feel
like the only reason we have the 2020
pro
with the imposter a12z chip is because
apple knew that the mini led displays
would be delayed
due to the coved lockdowns so they
slapped on some of the other features
that they were working on
and they put it up for sale to take
advantage of the lockdown demand
so what i'm trying to say is that while
the new ipad air
looks like an ipad pro killer apple is
going to release a new ipad pro
within half a year and it's going to
blow the roof
off of this ipad air i'm expecting
anywhere from 20
000 to 25 000 metal graphics score and
geekbench 5 which is rivaling the
graphics performance
of apple's 2400 dollar 16 inch macbook
pro
and we know that the new ipad pro is
going to have insane performance
because the upcoming apple silicon max
are going to be built
on the a14x chip and apple needs
those macs to have as much performance
as possible
to really prove that they made the right
call by ditching intel
so based on everything that we can learn
from the ipad air 4
the future of apple's ipads and the new
apple silicon mac lineup
is looking brighter than ever before but
getting back to the new air
is the new ipad air 4 worth buying right
now
well if you can't see yourself spending
at least eight hundred
to a thousand dollars on an ipad pro
then absolutely
yes the base 64 gigs of storage is
definitely the air's biggest downside
but it's still a great purchase because
it falls
in line with apple's modern design
scheme
looking just like the iphone 12 lineup
so it looks up to date and current
and on top of that i don't think that
the ipad pro is getting redesigned
just yet so that means that next year's
ipad air is going to stick with the same
design
or apple could even skip next year
completely
so in 4 to 5 years the ipad air 4 is
still going to look
modern while the older current ipads
like the budget ipad
and the current ipad mini 5 are gonna
look ancient
so right now is the perfect time to buy
the new ipad air but if you can see
yourself buying the
2021 ipad pro which will most likely
have a
shockingly powerful a14x chip
and a new mini led display then i would
honestly just wait another six months
to see what the new pro will offer
hopefully you guys enjoyed this review
and if you did go ahead and tap the like
button
and click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one
and definitely check out our ipad air
comparison videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one